38TH GOALTENDER IN NHL HISTORY
TO REACH THAT PLATEAU
>> Jody: THERE'S
KREBS THROWS IT BACK TO TO MY R
EXACTLY WHAT
HERE'S NYQUIST
THEY'RE FEELING
>> Jody: BROKEN PLAY THERE ENDS
UP IN  COZENS, OLOFSSON AND
KREBS FOLLOWING THE BOUNCING
PUCK I THE
POINT.
SABRES LOOK DOWN LOW AND IT JUST
RIFFLED WIDE.
ASPLUND TRYING TO PLAY THAT GOT.
KREBS COULD NOT PLAY..ON, AND S
THE PUCK QUICKLY.
HERE IT IS, IT ROLLS OVER THE
STICK OF   THERE
HE
COLUMBUS BLUE JACKETS.
HERE COMES PATRIK LAINE
ATTACKING THE MIDDLE, HE DOESN'T
AND JENNER JUST CHOPS IT DEEP.L.
BOTH TEAMS
PASS AND DROPPING TO MAKE THE
STOP, HOW MANY TIMES HAVE WE CH.
AND THEN THERE'SE-OFF AND DEAN
LOOKS LIKE HE GETS IT AS HE
CELE INTO THE S HYUNDAI DRIVE TO
THE NET.BOY.
>> Jody:.
>> Jody: LOOKS LIKE IT'S
OFFSIDE.
PUCK'S RIGHT HERE.
IT'S UP, NOT SURE IF WE CAN
DO THAT OR NOT.
THERE'S THE L
THERE'S LAINE WITH THE SHOT,
OE.
THERE HE'S BACK TO THE MIDDLE
NOW HE PUTS HIMSELF I ISEAT.
OR WILL HE? BEHIND THE
NET.
VORACEK IN PURSUIT.
WHERE
THEY THOUGHT THEY HAD A NE OF T
HE'S GOT I IT THERE FOR SAMUELS.
BACK HANDS BUT RIGHT IN THE
HALLWAY,Y, COMES UP HIGH
FOR THOMPSON, SEN THERE.
ICES I
FOR THE BLUE JACKETS.
HIGH.
6-3 COLUMBUS.
KREBS.
VETERAN